good morning John I'm headed to the
University of Montana you can see it
down there to see a cool thing that's
where I'm going okay
hi I made it this is Callie you may know
her from youtube.com slash Aeons this is
tuna mix I show most days you got your
name on the door where are we we are in
the University of Montana
paleontology Center collections around
this is the collections room it's back
there I mean I'm looking at this table
and like at least half of the things are
not awesome if the food is mostly
following the K okay what's your biggest
fossil probably that job serious
upstairs job fit anyway that case
upstairs we're gonna go obviously I try
to keep the heavier stuff on the lower
level let's see this these are all bits
of mammal mammoth I mean they are
mammals these are like tips of toes
oh it's lighter way lighter than I
expected yeah so this is all like in the
thousands of years old does that make it
lighter it does it there's less time for
the mineralization problem to occur
these are horse first bit a bunch of
horse bit the horses we have here now
we're important yeah from Europe yeah we
did have horses once yes and the og
horses horses started here yeah then
left so the weird cutoff date for a
fossil is ten thousand years right it's
completely arbitrary it's just like
nobody was like ten thousand a lot of
the big charismatic megafauna was
extinct by about ten thousand years ago
however mammoths hung on until about
four thousand years ago in High Arctic
Islands someone so that means when the
Great Pyramids of Egypt were being built
they were still mammoths hanging out in
the Arctic Circle this is so cute
yeah that's a little antler was it a
baby or was it just really little into
do you think they might have been
favored to teeth like like say bird like
tiny saber-tooth chihuahua deer I can't
even imagine there's so much cute stuff
oh yeah stuff with living breathing head
cells we run you never think about like
saber-toothed kittens they had to have
been yeah right stupid cute there's
little teeth and their teeth of ice
- teeth of rodents rodents how is that
different from just sand microscope my
favorite specimen specimen in the whole
collection up there top 5 so on the
outside you can tell that that's a
fossil but when you cut it open it's
just look at the pattern it's just it's
either a sponge or a hydro-zone oh okay
so it's like a soft thing mm-hmm but
I've had an internal structure do you
have any poop do we have poop
yes we have no Triassic poop oh I can't
believe you don't know where the turds
are I know and I just got them out the
other day
that's not turds hey I got my poop we
have some really amazing soft body
preservation what is that thing that's
terrible it's like more like a hell
warthog what sounds worse the top part
was what was eroding out you can just
like and still on it and then you asked
me about oldest specimen is it bacterial
Matt it is yeah from Australia of course
and it's like 2.75 billions
this is what life was so weird to think
about what earth was like when it was
just a just a baby yeah a few months ago
Kelly my friend Blake and I started a
YouTube show called yawns which is
basically the story of all life on Earth
but walking around this museum with
Callie I realized it's different for her
because she spends so much time with
these objects I got to see her see past
the bones into the animals and organisms
as they lived in their ecosystems in the
deep past and I think that really comes
out when she's talking about this stuff
thanks so much to Callie for the tour
and if you want to check out Aeons I
promise it is fascinating and weird and
amazing John I'll see you on Tuesday